ton papa il est pas là mon vrai papa il
est il est là il est pas là
c'est toi
tu peux me montrer ta maman
oh bonjour Geneviève
bonjour Linda
Linda maintenant c'est le moment des
enfants
un moment que je chéris particulièrement
Linda vous pouvez nous dire
concupiscence concupiscence
exceptionnelle un chanteur que
j'apprécie particulièrement j'ai nommé
Serge gains
[Applaudissements]
bonjour Serge tu vas bien
tu tu es content que de jeunes talent
interpréter chanson
tout de suite nos habitudes
c'est pas ton tour
[Musique]
comment tu t'appelles
tu
peux nous montrer ce que tu sais
[Rires]
[Musique]
bonjour
comment tu t'appelles Caroline et ton
nom
il est là dans la salle non il est pas
là oui
papa il est là il est pas là
allez on va voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
comment tu t'appelles
Philippe tu aimes ton prénom
qu'est-ce qu'on te fait à manger à la
maison
tu voudrais pas manger des frites on
fait pas des frites
à l'école oh oui tu vas voir plein de
copines oh non pas des copines oui il y
en a beaucoup
chatounet
dis-donc ton papa est dans la salle tu
peux me le montrer oh oui tu bois tu
bois le le monsieur avec le costume
saumon avec la gourmette en or et qui
sent bon
et ben c'est le gros qui bat à côté
et ta maman ta maman c'est la dame qui
est à côté du gros qui bat ah non c'est
pas ma maman ma maman c'est le monsieur
avec costume saumon dans la gueule
[Rires]
oh oui tu étais très très sale oui oui
je vais te faire une vidéo
ma petite quéquette sort de ma braquette
Jupiter je pète on monte ensuite
à tous les étages
[Applaudissements]
on
donne une note peut-être oui d'accord 07
oui au suivant
[Rires]
mais tu es une grande fille
tu vas à l'école
ton papa il est dans la salle
ta maman
comment tu t'appelles
c'est un joli prénom
[Rires]
32 ans
que je suis venu moi c'est pour
incroyable mais vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]